قلب الاسد 25 سؤال لازم نجاوب عليهم بسرعه
ومن غير تفكير متى حيبدا المجتمع يحترمك
بعد ما يحترمك بخمس دقائق
ايش اكثر شيخ خسرته بسبب عنادك
بريطانيه وانت كلب هجين هذه الخلطه ميزتك
بايش والله واجد الميزات يعني
واكثر شيء انفصام في الهويه تعب نفسي
اوكي مين عدوك اللدود في محافظه مسامير
طب ليش ساكن معه
من منطلق كبير انمي
هل سبب وفكرت في الهجره
وفكر تقاعد في خميس مشيط
طيب فين بتشوف نفسك بعد عشر سنين مرحوم
مرحوم
حمد ربه على طول طول العمر
طيب اوكي الله يطول عمرك ان شاء الله من
واحد لعشره لاي درجه انت ذكي
ممكن تعيدون السؤال
من واحد لعشره لاي درجه انت ذكي
طيب واخدك وقت تقرر طيب اوكي مو مشكله هل
لقيت نصك الثاني والله يعتمد على اداءك في
المقابله
[ضحك]
خلاص
عمرك ما لقيت ثاني طيب متى ستحصل على
البطوله المطلقه
اوكي طيب انت
ايش برايك اهم نصيحه للانتربينور الناجح
نصيحه للانتربينور الناجح ينولد في القصيم
كم تقضيت اجر على العمل
الروش اخذ
وعندكم التخلص من الجثه هذه
اتكلم على محافظه
اوكي هل خضعت
سويته ابتسامه بوليود
طيب ايش برنامجك المفضل
اي برنامج
طبعا دكتوره فوزيه رائعه
وعندها متابعين كثار كمان انت متهم
بالنجاسه كيف ترد والله
البشر
مين اكثر احد تكره بعد سعد غنام
طيب بتستعمل الفاظ خارجه كثير فين التربيه
يا طراد
والله يعني
لقيتها في المدرسه
اعتقد انها يمكن اكثر مقابله حكون ندمانه
عليها بس مش مشكله ايش الفرق بالعالم
الحيوان والانسان
او حكمه تحبه
اقعدوا عندي اثنين صراحه
يعني شويه يعني عكس بعض يعتمد على
[موسيقى]
محرج تيوس
محرج تيوس اوكي مين اكثر احد بتستمتع
بمتابعته اون لاين
يعني اكيد طبعا بس في محتوى معين يعني
بيعجبك والله احب الريكونتيش في المسلسلات
ممتاز اول اجابه تجاوبها تكون يعني كويسه
من يوتيوب المنصه عالميه زي نتفليكس
ومسلسلك صار مدبلج للغات خطوتك الجيه
عالميا تحب تكون مع مين
والله افكر امثل
خيار يعني
خيار جيد
جميل خلاص اوكي طيب انت تحب الغناء غني
لنا اغنيه تعبر عن حياتك
[موسيقى]
كمان الحقيقه خلينا نقول صريحين مع بعض بس
على العموم انه شكرا لك يا طراد يعني
الحمد لله
معلش يا ترى حياه الكلاب
والله انك بوحكي
هكذا